beautiful
you like the most
mom let's see I don't think I really
learned some youtubers because that's
not i'm not doing like what all these
other people are doing i was just like
I've been making videos since the 80s
and you know I just it's all soft odd i
started on like the oldest formats that
they had an audio tape I am when YouTube
came out it was like oh that's me you
know what I mean so I was just packing
up my hard drive to when I started
uploading videos it wasn't trying to get
noticed or get attention I was just
doing this for my descendants you know I
wanted my descendants to see what I was
like and and all that so I didn't really
pay the YouTube game when I went viral
then I kind of started seeing like oh
this is how it works and this you know I
mean I was a conscience of like an
audience or you know I think the whole
different game I'm so different than all
the other youtubers you know I mean I
have a video with no one in it right so
yeah it's all different for me what see
once you started
first ones that you saw just like a
style
well probably what am I mean how it
works for me is like they're my friends
first and then I go start watching him
because I meet them at these things and
like seven days after I started to go
viral this guy came out from LA and he
was like brother but one of my neighbors
is my friend and he made a video of me
and he kind of like he started getting
big on YouTube because of me and and but
he's huge now he's got like you know
half a million subscribers I don't know
how much that macaroni he's my buddy I
mean it's my my experience in higher
relate to is so different than everyone
else who's had success on YouTube yeah
cuz i'm not i'm not trying i don't want
I don't want this I just I'm doing what
I catch talk about yeah and it's just
the fame and the recognition is a side
effect of that
oh I wouldn't be here would be I want to
be at this conference but I mean my
whole life this does not change i have a
farm you know i'm working my farm and
it's like okay so i travel you know to
do these conferences from time to time
and i do a lot of interviews but 99% of
my life is exactly the same as it was I
wasn't ever going to change
you